hello and good morning it is 7am the
former prime minister gordon brown is
calling for the government's emergency
cobra committee to sit in permanent
session to try and tackle the cost of
living crisis and he's renewed his
demand for emergency budgets to help
families struggling to cope with rising
prices we'll be speaking to mr brown at
7 30 and we'll have representatives of
both the liz trust and rishi sunac
campaigns on the program to find out if
they agree and we'll be live in the
taiwanese capital taipei and jerusalem
it is monday the 8th of august
a ceasefire has come into force in gaza
after three days of israeli bombardment
killed at least 44 palestinians
this egyptian-backed ceasefire has now
come into effect but it's a temporary
truce it's not a long-standing solution
the biggest investment in stopping
climate change in u.s history the senate
approves a 369 billion dollar bill to
reduce carbon emissions
former prime minister gordon brown warns
of a race against time to get help to
those who need it most
arrest a fifth man in their
investigation into the disappearance of
the student nurse awami davies
she was last seen on this road in south
london on the 7th of july more than a
month ago
children's charities say they are
outraged after it is revealed that the
metropolitan police subjected 650
children to traumatizing strip searchers
in the last two years
the former manchester united star ryan
giggs is due to go on trial today
accused of attacking his ex-girlfriend
and also this morning
we'll speak to a student who found an
abandoned baby in a bin during a holiday
in haiti and gave him a home
and as the commonwealth games in
birmingham come to a close we'll discuss
the most memorable moments of the past
11 days with the president of the
commonwealth games federation
[Music]
hello and thank you for being with us a
ceasefire has come into force following
the worst violence between israel and
palestinian militants since the 11 day
war in 2021. at least 44 palestinians
have been killed in three days of
israeli bombardment on gaza hundreds of
rockets have been fired at israel
forcing people living there into
shelters but there were no fatalities
well let's cross now to jerusalem we're
joined by john sparks john good morning
to you so the ceasefire seems to be
holding for now but what's the feeling
among people there will it continue to
do so
yeah
very very uh good question it was
negotiated yesterday while the two sides
were busy trying to shoot and and bomb
each other it was announced very late
last night it was done by egypt who
seemed to be the only party at the
moment that can speak to all of the
parties involved but it is a temporary
truce a temporary settlement the status
quo remains at the same it doesn't
really change anything on the ground in
gaza and around
gaza
it started on friday this episode of
violence the israelis carried out what
they called preemptive attacks on
positions belonging to the second
largest militant
group in gaza called islamic jihad
islamic jihad then struck back with more
than 600 rockets that they fired into
israel
we saw people scurrying for the shelters
in cities like tel aviv and ashkelon
and a very difficult situation for
people in israel but there were no
casualties here not the same in gaza
more than 44 people in gaza including
some children
have lost their lives more than 300
people have been injured and multiple
buildings in gaza have been destroyed as
well so
the fear the anger the resentment that
all remains in gaza and the security
concerns in israel that stays the same
as well but we do have at the moment a
sort of peace
okay john in jerusalem for now thank you
so much for that reporting thank you
now the former prime minister gordon
brown is calling for daily meetings of
the government's emergency cobra
committee to try and deal with the cost
of living crisis now he warns of a
financial time bomb issue to explode on
families on the first of october that's
when energy prices rise and he sharply
criticizes both conservative leadership
hopefuls well here with me now is the
former conservative party co-chairman
and supporter of rishi sunic oliver
dowden uh oliver good morning to you
thank you for watching with us let's
pick up on what we've heard from the
prime minister right now a good idea to
hold daily emergency cobra meetings well
of course we need to be on top of this
situation and we need to be
realistic and honest with people about
the scale of the challenge that we're
facing both with the scale of inflation
that's coming down the line something we
haven't seen for almost 40 years and
with the fact that energy bills are
going to go up possibly towards 4 000
pounds i would say though i don't take
enormous lessons from gordon brown
remember this was a man who gave the 75p
rise for pensioners so he's not really
got a great record on this sort of thing
oh he's also the man who guided the
country through the financial crisis in
2008.
we we we could trade stuff about gordon
brown he's also the person that left us
with no money left and uh
sold the gold at the lowest price
possible so um i think conservatives are
perfectly capable of dealing with this
situation ourselves and you've seen that
rishi sunak did that when he was
chancellor he announced an enormous
amount of support for people uh in
expectation of this rise in energy bills
up to 1 200 pounds for those on the
lowest incomes it's that kind of scale
of direct intervention that is required
and i think uh
just uh proposing to cut the national
insurance contribution which will only
help people on the lowest incomes
working full-time the national living
wage by less than 60 pounds it is not
sufficient to this scale of challenge
listen this trust is not gordon brown's
we'll come on to some of that in a
moment do you think there should be an
emergency budgets then whoever is next
prime minister to deal with the crisis
we're facing uh well i think we need to
take bold and direct action in response
to this and i think uh you've seen from
rishi sunak when he was chancellor both
in response to the furlough scheme
when he came up with that in a matter of
days that saved millions of jobs and the
action he and prime minister boris
johnson took earlier this year it's that
kind of scale of intervention that is
required not an emergency budget bolton
direct action is one thing an emergency
budget is what's needed isn't it well
these things don't necessarily have to
be done through an emergency budget so
if you look at the 1200 pounds that was
announced earlier this year that wasn't
through an emergency budget but i think
there is no doubt that we do need uh an
intervention of a considerable scale
to deal with this because we have to be
honest with people about the scale of
the challenge that they're facing so
that's an acceptance then the amount
that was promised earlier in the year is
inadequate and more money will be needed
for those most in need yes i think
that's that's almost certainly the case
we'll have to see exactly what the the
bills end up uh being we know they're
gonna be three and a half thousand well
let's see when we know the exact level
of the price cap but if if it looks like
it's going to be at that kind of scale
then of course we'll need further
intervention so we have already seen
an announcement from rishi soon that
that he would remove vat on fuel bills
temporarily to help through this crisis
but i'm sure that further action will
also be required what about an increase
in universal credit to help those most
in need who will be suffering
well actually if you you look at
universe credit that is something that
uh racist was willing to do both during
the the covert crisis when he increased
it by 20 pounds and indeed uh when he
eased the taper rate to help people
uh to to keep more of what they earn on
those lower incomes but i think that
then he took it away so i mean we're
going into another huge crisis now in
the winter will that happen again do you
think
well we've been clear that support will
be temporary and targeted so the vat cup
will be temporary when bills fall again
then that support won't be required but
i think the point about all of this is
and i think there is a genuine a
difference of opinion between uh
liz trust and reggie sunak on this that
that richardson accepts the need for
this these bold big interventions uh
liz trust has put her emphasis on this
tax cut and it's important for your
viewers to understand what that tax cut
means for the prime minister whoever the
prime minister is that'd be worth 1 800
pounds a year a considerable sum up to
the the scale of the increase in bills
for somebody working full time on the
national living wage is worth less than
60 pounds so we need more and bigger
direct intervention support people and
that's why i was somewhat concerned by
the the position announced uh on
saturday in the financial times by by
liz trust again it's not entirely clear
what what the position is now on that i
mean you're not clear i don't know if
we're clear we're going to speak to
brandon lewis uh later in the program to
find out exactly where it is so you
think just list trust just doesn't get
the scale of the challenge we're facing
i think liz trusts a very um capable
person i've had the pleasure of working
with her for a number of years this is
not about a personal thing this is about
judgement though as a a leader of the
conservative party and prime minister
and i think what you've seen with rishi
sunak is the judgment that he showed
when he dealt with the cobart crisis
it's that kind of big intervention that
is required and my concern is that if we
simply rely on a reduction in the
national insurance contribution rights
then that is not going to help the
neediest people but it will help uh
people on higher incomes it won't for
example help pensioners no it won't
let's just talk a little bit about which
you see like of course you will have
seen uh for the past few days this video
doing the rounds on social media
officially soon act speaking in
tonbridge wells talking about making
sure that money would be going to
areas like that taken away from deprived
communities making sure it was spread
out i mean that has left i think a bit
of a sour taste in his mouth let's
vote as well let's have a listen to that
i managed to start changing the funding
formulas to make sure that areas like
this
are getting the funding that they
deserve because we inherited a bunch of
formulas from the labor party that
shoved all the funding into deprived
urban areas uh then they you know that
needed to be undone i started the work
of undoing that
i mean he said he's gonna undo that i
mean that might play well in tunbridge
wells probably doesn't play well in
places like darlington where he's going
to be later in the week and it certainly
wouldn't play well if he came up against
labour in a general election would it
well i think the the point that rishi
was making with which i agree completely
is that we need to focus resources on
when they're where they're most needed
and it's quite easy so if you just let
me finish this point it's quite easy to
dismiss the southeast of england say
there's not a deprivation there if you
take my own constituency of heart smear
it has some of the most affluent places
in the country in it but right next door
in the same constituency
one of the wards is in the the 10 of
most deprived wards in the country now
it's right that places like that should
get support as part of leveling up and
that's precisely what rishi sunak has
been saying i think what you saw under
the labour party was large amounts of of
resource going into inner cities and
ignoring those areas of deprivation that
exist across the whole country and i
think it's it's perfectly right that
rishi has seen that changed the formula
in that way somebody should be going to
leafy places like tunbridge wells as
opposed to places that are perhaps more
urban it needs to be
in the the most needing places and that
doesn't just have to be in urban inner
city areas and i see that in my own
constituency why do we think that richie
sunek is behind in in many of the polls
that we're seeing right now that mr
darden well i i've been in politics
well i'm not saying you can't trust the
polls what i am saying is we have seen
time and time again that polls have not
proved to be correct whether that's in
relation to brexit donald trump you you
name it all different polls come out the
key thing is the members i trust the
members of this this party i work with
her incredibly closely as chairman and
over many years i know that in the end
they'll look at the candidates and they
can seem risky sooner someone with the
values with the experience and the
capability to lead our nation okay
oliver to the former chair of the
conservative party thanks for your time
this morning thank you very much okay
now the financial times uh let's look at
the papers now and start with the
financial times which leads with the
conservative leadership candidate liz
truss appearing to contradict herself
over whether to offer cash handouts to
people struggling with the cost of
living crisis as i just said oliver dada
will check that with brandon lewis when
he's on the show a little later on
that's also the main story for the daily
express which says that mistrust has not
ruled out offering more help to people
the times has a poll which suggests
voters want candidates to control
inflation before cutting tax
and the mirror goes with that call that
we're talking about there from gordon
brown for the government's emergency
cobra committee to hold daily meetings
to deal with the crisis that many
families are facing
now the guardian says it's seen leaked
documents which suggests that the
justice secretary dominic raab wants to
make it harder to bring legal challenges
against the government
and the daily telegraph carries a
warning from the health secretary that
action needs to be taken immediately to
prevent a winter crisis in the nhs
and finally according to the daily mail
conservative mps investigating the prime
minister over partygate have been urged
to quit what his supporters call a
kangaroo court
well still to come on the programme at
half past seven we'll be speaking to the
former prime minister gordon brown but
what more he wants to see from the
government to deal with the cost of
living crisis including those daily
meetings of the emergency cobra
committee
and at a quarter to eight i'll be joined
by the former president of yougov peter
kellner for our polling pit stop
and i'll also be speaking to a 10 year
old girl from afghanistan who shares her
experiences after her family fled here
to the uk a year ago to the fall of
kabul
now the united states senate has passed
a bill which will pump more than 400
billion dollars into the fight against
climate change the us is the world's
second biggest polluter and democrats
hope that the bill will cut the
country's greenhouse gas emissions by 40
by the end of the decade david blevins
reports
death and destruction in kentucky the
flash flooding there last week
illustrating the scale of the climate
crisis facing america it's an issue
coast to coast but there hadn't been any
serious legislative approach to tackling
it for 34 years with the senate evenly
split the vice president arrived to
exercise her crucial casting vote
the a's are 50 the nays are 50 the
senate being equally divided the vice
president votes in the affirmative and
the bill as amended is passed
it's the largest investment any u.s
government has ever made to counter
global warming nearly 400 billion
dollars over 10 years
big tax breaks for those who switch to
green energy and penalties for companies
who failed to reduce their emissions
the democrats pushed it through despite
fierce opposition from republicans even
though i prefer to work in a bipartisan
way when it's really important
and the republicans won't participate we
have to do it on our own and that's the
opportunity even with 50 votes that
reconciliation affords us and that's
what we that's what we used
as wildfires continue to rage in
california the battle goes on between
environmentalists and the fossil fuel
industry in the united states but
president biden's climate commitments
are back on track a big boost for the
white house with midterm elections
looming
david blevins sky news in washington
well now to the growing rift over taiwan
the country's defense ministry says it
detected 66 chinese planes and 14
warships taking part in live fight
exercises over the weekend now they've
accused china of behaving like a bully
i'm joined now from taipei by the
reporter for taiwan plus james chater
james good to have you with us again so
just tell us how has this weekend been
these exercises are continuing on um how
are people on the island feeling
well people you know remain remain
relatively calm
we had the official conclusion of these
drills a day yesterday um but you know
after that the taiwanese defense
ministry was coming out and saying that
the airspace around taiwan had returned
to relative normality however today
chinese officials now saying that drills
are continuing around taiwan the eastern
theater command that's the part of the
chinese military that has really been
the driving force of a lot of these
drills saying on social media that they
will continue anti-submarine and sea
raids the location of these drills is
still not known um but taiwan's defense
ministry is going to have a press
conference within the next hour or so to
discuss this
all of this comes after china saying
yesterday that there would be continuing
drills along the the median line of the
taiwan strait that's the body of water
that sepa separates taiwan from china
and also more drills are going to be
taking place in the boar high sea in the
yellow sea of china's northeastern coast
speaking some of the defense analysts
we're basically hearing now that this is
going to mark a new kind of phase in
terms of how china seeks to prosecute
its military and intimidating military
tactics towards taiwan from the
perspective of beijing they will argue
that they're kind of justified in doing
this because
you know from the perspective of beijing
the u.s sending nancy pelosi to taiwan
was itself a violation of that policy um
i think you know the concern of
taiwanese officials is that the visit of
pelosi is going to set up this kind of
situation where there's a kind of point
of no return and you know that china is
going to have to ramp up this type of
military intimidation because you know
if if they don't keep the the pressure
at this level
the military deterrence and trying to
dissuade other foreign officials from
traveling to taiwan is going to start to
lose its teeth so you know pelosi's
visit we're really starting to see now
the dust has settled on this trip the
longer term effects of um what this trip
and the live five drills that followed
it are really going to be doing and a
lot of analysts saying that we're
starting to see a new normal across the
taiwan straits
you normally indeed okay james shay are
in taipei do appreciate that thank you
now the un secretary general antonio
guterres says that a recent attack on a
nuclear power station in ukraine is
suicidal the zapolicio nuclear power
station came under fire late on saturday
and both the ukrainians and russia
accuse each other of being responsible
for it
people in kenya will be heading to the
polls tomorrow as they look to elect a
new president the race to replace
president uru kenyatta is likely to be a
close contest between ryla odinga the
longtime opposition leader is making his
fifth run for the presidency and william
ruto kenyatta's deputy who previously
had a falling out with the
president now police have arrested a
fifth man in their investigation into
the disappearance of the student nurse
awami davis she was last seen a month
ago while in south london while joining
me now is our correspondent madeline
ratcliffe for more on this good morning
to you maddie so uh what's going on with
the investigation just tell us where we
are right now
good morning well awami davies was seen
on this road at derby road in croydon
south london she was picked up in the
early hours of the morning on the
thursday the 7th of july by cctv in a
shop and also by the cctv camera you can
see behind me here on derby road
and she was seen in that cctv the police
have since released those pictures as
part of their investigation um there was
a later uh that morning 7am an
unconfirmed sighting of her as well on
nearby clarendon road but
um that was three days after she left
her family home in essex and the
metropolitan police's specialist crime
unit is now investigating trying to work
out what happened to her a month ago now
over a month ago and they have now
arrested a fifth person as part of those
investigations a 27 year old man on
suspicion of kidnap that brings the
total to three people arrested on
suspicion of kidnap two people arrested
on suspicion of murder and four of those
people have now been bailed but the
police say they are still investigating
it is very complex case
they are trawling through cctv they say
but they have renewed their appeals to
members members of the public for
information
okay madeline for now thank you so much
our children's charities say they are
horrified after it was revealed that
more than 600 children were subjected to
strip searches by the metropolitan
police in the past two years many
without an appropriate adult being
present emma birchley has this
the case of child q prompted protests in
a serious case review
why was a 15 year old black girl strip
searched by the metropolitan police at
school without an appropriate adult
but data released by the children's
commissioner for england has revealed
that hundreds of young people go through
such intrusive searches each year often
unaccompanied
as strip searches you know your most
intimate parts are searched for any
child that's going to be traumatic and
concerning
and so i think it's for safeguarding
it's absolutely clear that an
appropriate adult should be there
it's actually a legal requirement except
in the most urgent of cases
but between 2018 and 2020
650 children aged 10 to 17 were strip
searched 58 of whom were black
95 were boys and on nearly a quarter of
occasions an appropriate adult was not
present
in fact in 2018 more than two-thirds of
those strip-searched alone were black
boys
the numbers are so high because they
demonstrate that there's an issue within
the metropolitan police and its
treatment of black communities across
london unfortunately young black
children are not afforded innocents and
the same rights as their white pairs and
i'm unsurprised by these statistics but
incredibly horrified
in the child q case four officers are
being investigated for gross misconduct
the metropolitan police says it's
progressing at pace to ensure that
children subject to intrusive searches
are dealt with respectfully and new
measures are being introduced requiring
an inspector to give authority before
such a search can take place
solicitor kevin donahue has represented
children who've been through the
experience
there is a violation
by police officers which is very
severely felt
and
one of personal integrity and their
bodily autonomy
which has been invaded and it is an
event that cannot be undone
in more than half of all child strip
searches no further action was taken
it's left the children's commissioner
questioning why so many are carried out
in the first place
emma birchley sky news
and we're going to be speaking to the
children's commissioner rachel souza
later on this morning onto some of
today's other headlines now and
investigations are continuing into the
death of an 11 year old girl who went
missing at a water park on saturday what
happened is being treated as unexplained
the park liquid leisure in windsor
remains closed
the former manchester united star ryan
giggs goes on trial today accused of
assaulting his ex-girlfriend and
controlling and coercive behavior mr
giggs pleaded not guilty to all charges
against him in july of 2021.
around 70 firefighters and 10 fire
engines tackled a large fire in west
london on sunday smoke could be seen
from planes landing nearby heathrow 60
people were forced to leave their homes
the cause of the fire is not yet known
the school's minister will quint says
that england must maintain the value of
qualifications as exam results are
expected to fall the government is
predicting very few schools and colleges
will top their 2021 grades which were
awarded by teacher review due to the
pandemic mr quint says that young people
universities and employers still believe
that exams are the best and fairest
method of assessment
well
i'm pleased to say that the former prime
minister gordon brown joins us now live
for more on his plans to try and deal
with the cost of living prices gordon
brown good morning to you thank you very
much for being with us here on skype so
first of all what would be achieved by
holding daily emergency cobra meetings
well we've got um energy crisis we've
got an inflation crisis we're going to
have a national health service
waiting list crisis
what uh cobra meeting and that's the
emergency committee that we hold when
things are difficult has got to do is
ensure there's enough energy for the
winter ensure there's enough storage
facilities
ensure that
we can
get the cost of living help to people
because we've only seven weeks to go
before october the first you've got to
change the universal credit computer to
enable it to make payments to people and
there's no doubt that people are going
to go without food and they're going to
go hungry and cold in october if we
don't take action now so this is the
time to take action and that's why i'm
saying that
the government ministers should be
meeting with the two leadership
candidates so that they can agree a
package that could be implemented
immediately if not parliament should be
recalled to look at what is a national
emergency and at the same time of course
at the special committee should be
meeting to look at all these plans
you know you could be looking at a cap
on energy prices you could be doing what
norway does and say we'll pay eighty
percent of the increase in bills or you
could have better social security
support but all these things are not
really being discussed by government
ministers at the moment not even the
leadership candidates who are obsessed
about tax cuts we've really got to deal
with this cost of living crisis the
supply of energy shortages of uh storage
facilities but also deal with the cost
of living costs that people are having
to pay
now they're saying that of course that
when whichever one of them takes office
comes into office they will address it
then this trust says there'll be an
emergency buzzer and richie sunak says
as oliver daddy just told us that all
measures um will be taken when necessary
why do you think that during the
campaign
more of this happen
but that's too late
yeah that's too late because you need
this time now to make decisions if
you're going to affect things on october
the first it takes weeks to change the
benefits system and undoubtedly we will
need to pay people more money so if you
have a budget let's say in the second
week of september you might get benefits
to people before christmas uh if you
have rushes soon accept plan that he's
going to look at it later
then it will be too late
the prime minister i understand is now
back from holiday today
the chancellor should be there and they
should be talking to the two leadership
candidates and agree a package now
if they agree as they're now agreeing
then this has started over the weekend
but there is action that has to be taken
it should not wait for another month or
two it should be taken now
um what are you saying to the labour
party of course because uh as a former
prime minister mr brown while your words
are very well respected obviously you
can't influence what the current party
is doing what can you what are you
saying to the current shadow cabinets
what do you want to see them doing
well of course they're saying that
there's an urgent crisis and
things have got to be done and they have
proposed a series of measures to deal
with the heating crisis what's happened
however which makes it
urgent in the last few weeks is that we
now know that heating bills are going to
rise even faster in october and then
again in january so we're dealing with
the severity of the crisis 15 million
households to be hit
we're also dealing with the scale of it
that some households will lose about 35
to 40 pounds a week they'll be short in
having to pay their bills and will be
unable to pay their bills and of course
we're dealing with the social
consequences children and care
homelessness mental health problems all
of which will cost money if we don't
take action to try to alleviate some of
these anxieties you know i talk to
charities in my own area here in
scotland quite a lot and they are
dreading october they are stocking up on
their duvets and sleeping bags and hot
water bottles and sheets and pillows and
blankets because they know that people
can't afford to heat their homes anymore
and the best we can hope is people
heating themselves i talk to churches
and faith groups into their great credit
they're thinking of opening their church
halls as heating hubs so that pensioners
instead of freezing at home can have a
warm place to go to now if charities
and organizations in the community are
taking urgent action to do something i
think it's about time the government
responded the vacuum at the center of
government really has got to end
i mean you made that very clear mr brown
but if if you were in downing street
right now what would you do today this
week
to make a real difference to those
people facing those catastrophic bills
on the 1st of october
well the first thing i would do is call
the meeting together with the leadership
candidates because they've got to
approve what the prime minister would be
proposing i think the chancellor's got
to be back so that we do first of all we
look at what we can do to help people uh
pay the bills over the winter we know
that they're going to be short of
maybe up to 1500 pounds this year and
that's some of the poorest families in
the country we know that tax cuts will
not make the difference because they go
to people who have got the most money
not people who've got the least money so
i would be talking about changes in the
universal credit system to give people
the money that is necessary
and i would be talking about potentially
capping energy bills and that would have
the effect of getting inflation down as
well as of course of helping people in
the greatest need but none of these
things seem to be being discussed at the
moment in the way they should be and it
really is not good enough for leadership
candidates to go around the country say
i'll have a plan next month the month
after this is the crisis that's got to
be addressed now if we're going to help
people by the 1st of october so my
measures about changes in the benefit
system
helping particularly families with
children and pensioners and disabled
people who've lost out from richie sunex
previous packages
and of course looking at how we can deal
with the energy companies now if you
want to pay for it
i would say that the windfall tax could
raise 15 billion pounds
when the government is only proposing to
raise 5 billion pounds and that's
because richie sooneck built in all the
opt-outs for the energy companies if
they invested more and so on and so
forth let's just get the money in
because there are excess profits that
are windfall that are not due to the
success of the companies but due to the
changes in the energy market and that's
something that they should not
necessarily benefit from but the public
should get the money instead
so change to the benefit system i took
from that you want to see an increase in
the amount that the poorest households
receive and you're going to pay for it
with another windfall tax i mean it's
hard enough getting the government to
agree to the first one another one at
this stage
no it's the same windfall tax it's just
removing all the opt-outs what richie
sunak did rather stupidly in my view was
said i'll agree with the labour party
who's proposed this windfall tax we'll
put it at 25 percent as they propose but
we'll give companies they opt out that
they can claim all their expenses
against this tax with the result that
he's reduced the value of the tax from
15 billion to 5 billion now 10 billion
could give people on universal credit a
huge amount of additional money over the
winter months to be able to cope with
these heating bills you see what's
actually happened let's be clear about
this the government in many ways to the
credit have offered twelve hundred
pounds to families in greatest need but
that's not enough because they lost a
thousand pounds
when universal credit was taking away
benefits are only going up three percent
but inflation's eleven percent so that's
roughly another thousand pounds loss and
now we've got these big rises announced
last week that are going to happen in
october and january in heating bills and
that's at least another few hundred
pounds and so anything the government
has done has already been wiped out and
they have got to do more now other
countries i look at germany at france at
spain and portugal and norway and
they're doing more than we are doing and
it's about time that the government took
action and the only time that really
matters is when you're planning for the
winter months it's too late if you do
the changes in november or december
you've got to help people in october so
they're not going hungry and children
will go to school ill-clad and
undernourished if we don't do something
about it and pensioners will have to
choose between feeding themselves and
feeding their gas and electricity meters
mr brown you said that we're expecting a
financial time bomb to go off on the 1st
of october obviously you were in office
where another financial time bomb or not
even time on the time a bomb went off
while you're in office and you and you
guided the country or were helping the
country through that so would you like
to return to frontline politics now do
you think
no i think when you're out you're out
and you've got to accept that that's
what's happened but i do feel very
strongly about this you know i i live in
the place i was brought up in in fife in
my county and i am seeing poverty that i
did not expect to see ever again in my
lifetime you know i grew up in a mining
and textiles town which went through a
long period of unemployment and now
unfortunately we're back to some of the
conditions we saw then when people have
not the money to turn up the heating
when they're having to tell the children
they cannot give them basic necessities
when people are in charities and you
know in my uh town and county people
don't have a lot but they help people
with nothing but the people who don't
have a lot are also running out of money
and not able to help so food banks need
more help but they cannot do it on their
own charities cannot solve this problem
on their own no matter how well-meaning
they are it's really up to the
government now and in every other
country there is a recognition of this
crisis and people are acting now and
it's time for this government no matter
what's happening in the tory leadership
contest they should all get together and
see if they can agree on a program but
it's got to happen in the next few days
i want to push you a little bit on that
if i can mr brown i know important
duties to you and service and
your experience may well be essential at
this time so if you were asked to come
back in would you
it's not going to happen i mean you just
held oliver dowden on your program this
morning making all sorts of party
political allegations against me which
are completely wrong of course but i
know them because what i'm interested in
is what is in the interests of the
people of this country and i can help
and i'm working with local charities to
do so but the most important thing is
that those who have got elective power
for the time being that they take the
action that is necessary you know it's
ridiculous at the time of this crisis
that the prime minister and the
chancellor have both been on holiday the
foreign secretary and richie sunak the
former chancellor on the campaign trail
and nobody seems in charge now of course
i could walk in tomorrow and say this is
what the cobra committee should do and
i'm telling you what i think it should
do but of course i'm realistic enough to
know that the conservatives are in power
and it's their turn to take the action
that is necessary and if not make way
for kia stammer who's ready and waiting
to do good things and would you work for
secure stamina then mr brown
kierstama is going to be a great prime
minister of this country and i think
everybody knows he's a person of
integrity uh he's made the right
decisions uh to rejuvenate the labour
party and i think he is the person that
people can turn to with a great deal of
hope as well as a huge amount of trust
and would you work in a cabinet that he
set up sir
i'm not going to be invited back but uh
obviously i'm here to help and
i i'm
you know too young to be an american
politician when you look at the ages of
american politicians but i know that
it's uh it's time for other people to
take their helm and look the team that
kierstama is bringing together is is
incredibly impressive and uh i think you
can look forward to something uh in our
politics that will make a radical change
in the way that we do things you see
what i find amazing at the moment is
there is a huge crisis we had covered
we've got obviously to recover still
from that and the national health
service also needs uh urgent attention
about how we can avoid these winter
crises and the big waiting list but it
does need the people who are empowered
to get together to do it and you know
this cannot uh be happen quickly enough
it's got to happen now
okay uh gordon brown former prime
minister of course former chancellor
championship do appreciate your time
this morning sir thank you so much for
being with us
thank you
all right let's bring in our political
correspondent murray aurora and the
former president of you go peter kellner
who are listening into that with me in
the studio mari peter love you to have
you with us peter will come to you in a
moment murray first of all what did you
make of what you heard from mr brown
well it was very interesting uh some of
the things he was talking about when you
asked him when you pressed him on how
exactly he would not just pay for those
new measures he wants to put in place so
we talked about universal credit and how
he would change that system and how he
wants to pay for that not for the new
windfall tax but with changing the old
windfall tax that he says rishi sunak
didn't implement properly enough for the
stupidest stupid that was to encourage
investment the reason that kava was put
in place wasn't it yes exactly and i
think that was what uh vishy sunak and
the tory party were concerned about when
they were thinking of implementing this
room for attack so it's not surprising
otherwise people might get to the point
where they say well what's the
difference between labor and tories and
always very worried about that winfor
tax and having to kind of u-turn when
they said they weren't going to so it
was a very interesting a little
interview there from gordon brown
obviously we know he's told you he's not
going back into politics but it the
thing that i find interesting is
we have a former prime minister labour
prime minister trying to inspire change
trying to put pressure on the government
to do something yet
kirstama not necessarily making the same
level of waves so i think some people
might think to themselves okay well
labour should be in a very good position
now and they're not and they're not
doing that well in the polls
they're not that well known and that
popular with the public why is that and
someone like gordon brown obviously he's
saying that kirsten's team are very
impressive
and then he he's a quote here he's
talked about uh you can expect radical
change from kierstama where he'd be
prime minister now i think some people
might find that a bit of a stretch
because i think radicals probably not
one of the words not everybody would use
to describe kierstarma so i think this
in a sense could be a very friendly push
to kierstama to really get out there
show the nation what he's made of show
the nation his vision and if he really
wants to be taken seriously in the next
general election there are potential
whisperings around a snap election in
the autumn we don't know if that's
coming obviously liz trust has ruled
that out but i think it might be a
gentle push to uh kiss armor to uh
essentially try and inspire the nation a
little bit more and get out there just a
thought from you on what we heard from
oliver dowd as well before we spoke to
gordon brown he was very critical of
gordon bound's financial credentials um
and also obviously was full-throated in
his support for rishi soon again his
plan as opposed to the plan we're
hearing from lizarus yeah exactly yeah a
bit of a dig there too at gordon brown
obviously understandably he's a tory and
gordon brown's labour prime minister but
he talks about kind of reinstating trust
and honesty in a new prime minister with
rishi sunayak we can take a look at this
clip and he explains what wishi-sunak's
vision is
i think we need to take bold and direct
action in response to this and i think
uh you've seen from rishi sunak when he
was chancellor both in response to the
furlough scheme uh when he came up with
that in a matter of days that saved
millions of jobs and the action he and
prime minister boris johnson took
earlier this year it's that kind of
scale of intervention that is required
well let's bring in a peter kellner now
for more on this i mean that's the line
coming from the camp the sunac camp but
let's look at some of the latest polls
peter because it doesn't really bear out
that that message is getting across to
those who are going to be voting but
that's right um opinion and their fault
likely for yesterday's observer uh asked
people who they thought would make the
better prime minister liz
or rishi sunak and i think it was
absolutely decisive it was more than two
to one in favor of liz trust there we
are 48 percent let's trust 22 percent to
register this is conservative voters now
conservative voters of course don't have
a vote in the leadership contest but
what's interesting
is the ratio a bit over two to one is
pretty well identical to the two surveys
we had last week uh of tory party
members and the second thing is other
opinions figures uh results show a clear
move amongst voters towards this trust
over the last fortnight which is exactly
what the polls of tory party members
have shown so all the data from however
it's done with whomever it's done is
moving in the same direction and this
trust is pretty well out of sight i mean
would we would have putting that down to
just the way that she's pulling away
from she sunk right now
i think what it is um it's to do with
character actually more than policy you
what is interesting to us
those of us who follow politics
professionally is we see a battle for
the conservative party about two
different kinds of right of center
politics and therefore the result is is
profound in its impact on british
politics but the people who are voting
i think on the whole what what what
comes through clearly from the polls is
that people think rishi said i think
he's he's decisive he's competent he
looks like a prime minister in waiting
but
they don't trust him right they don't
think he's in touch with ordinary voters
and those are the two things where liz
trust scores very highly whether you
talk to party members or the general
public at the moment with all everything
that's going on with with energy
prices inflation tax and so on
voters and party members really do want
somebody who they think is on their side
and that's where this trust goes let's
have a look at that sorry murray
question actually um so with the liz
trust and the fact that she's coming out
on top of honesty do you think uh those
two u-turns that she's been accused of
has negatively impacted her campaign or
does it look like in the numbers not at
all
my honest guess
is that that has been noticed by far
fewer people than we who report these
things i'm sorry if this depresses you
because you've been saying this day
after day but i'm not sure these kind of
things really strike through they can if
they keep going for three or four days
but the liz trusts u-turn you know it
lasted what 24 hours
okay let's have a look at uh the cost of
living crisis and how it's uh affecting
the way people are feeling about this is
the impact of inflation bring up these
numbers here now talk us through the the
right figures we've got here how are
they coping uh with with um
household budgets and you see a third
are either not coping at all seven
percent or struggling twenty six add
moves together thirty three percent a
third of the public that's a big number
but in the midlands and north
the figure is not 33 percent adding
those two together but 46
so think about the reds wall seats which
the tories are desperate to hold on to
this is a real problem across the
country and a devastating problem in the
seats the tories must hold and does it
tell us as well anything about the way
that voters feel the candidates are
actually trying to address these
concerns well this is where liz trust i
think scores because
i think a lot of voters a lot of top
tourney party members fairly or unfairly
think that somebody who's a
multi-millionaire
worth hundreds of millions of pounds
can't possibly really grasp what it's
like to be struggling with energy bills
that are going up to 2000 to 3 000.
three and a half thousands and they do
think liz trust gets that and this trust
is if you like backstory growing up in a
comprehensive school in new york and so
on that does chime with the people who
are making this uh decision let's look
at the uh our final uh bit of polling
from over the weekend this is on the
front page of the times this is all
about what is most important for the
next prime minister
to do i mean 64 percent think that they
should get inflation under control but
this is fascinating because if you think
on those figures russia soon i could be
walking away with this contest because
that's his message you know the 64
percent agree with the view let's get
inflation under control and then think
about taxes so why is he behind a couple
of reasons the first is that you gov
same question to lose trust supporters
find that um it's almost half say reduce
taxes not 17
so that's going down better
the and the second thing is that liz
truss is denying that's a trade-off
she's saying in effect
we can both cut taxes and keep inflation
down and i think a lot of people feel
that
that
if there's going to be a trade-off they
want inflation first but liz trust is
saying you can have your k-10 diesels
but that credibility gap in that doesn't
seem to be affecting household polling
doesn't necessarily mean exactly and
this is coming back to the point
i made earlier this is as much about
character as about policy and um
and liz trust being on people's side and
being trustworthy compared with rishi
sunak
a lot of elections where the general
elections or party elections are often
much more about the character of the
contestants than about specific policies
so if people felt there was that
trade-off if everybody thought that was
that trade-off and if they felt that
rishi sunac was just as much on their
side as liz trust then i think we should
say like will probably be ahead but
those two things actually don't apply
yeah um you're going to have a question
when i was in worcester with tory party
members last week inflation and tax cuts
came up never they did not talk about it
at all they weren't interested in it so
i'm curious to you how much do we know
about the demographics of tory party
members people about 30 seconds left and
then and therefore how important
inflation is to them because that's who
they need to win over 40 percent of tory
party members the people voting this
election are over 65 they're my
generation not your generation and they
do have different priorities after all
they're not paying national insurance
for example so so so there is a
demographic tilt and they're also far
more southern than the northern southern
and elderly that's your typical tory
voter and that's not the same as the
country as a whole
okay peter killed our lovely stuff
murray roy we'll speak to you again
later thank you so much both i love this
coach thank you all right now
on to the games and the commonwealth
games are going to draw to a close in
birmingham today after 11 days of
competition but had the hundreds of
millions of pounds it cost to stage them
been worth it becky johnson reports
the star of the opening ceremony
now a star attraction the commonwealth
games have breathed new life into
birmingham
busy bright and bustling
[Music]
the city center is buzzing
you can't sum it up to be honest this is
something that's brought everybody
together as you can see all everybody
from all walks of life so it's fantastic
people are very hyped about this it's
it's really good
great for the athletes too
england's nick miller taking gold in the
hammer throw the energy in the stadium
for this championships has just been
overwhelming um
i mean the roar of the crowd is
unbelievable
and it's not just the home fans but the
many visitors to the city impressed by
what they've seen
oh no it's
fair crack during um during the games
obviously there's a bit of buzz around
yeah it's it's a great atmosphere great
city to be around it's a lot more modern
than i was thinking because yeah we've
got this idea that it's really
industrial that old image of birmingham
has been replaced by pictures shown
around the world of a revitalized city i
would say the games have been huge for
birmingham it's put birmingham on the
map not only the uk but more importantly
worldwide it's showing the city is open
for business and that business couldn't
be more welcome in a city center that
fell quiet during covered we've really
struggled after pandemic not really sure
and a bit uncertainty about how things
would go but it's been great to see the
city alive and we've been extremely busy
from about five minutes after we open
our doors every day so it's been great
it's been fantastic organizers promised
that the games would bring investment
and improvement to birmingham but the
price was high
778 million pounds of public money were
spent delivering these games the
challenge is to make that count by
building on all of this to create a
lasting legacy for the future
but for now they're celebrating success
becky johnson sky news birmingham